on a là on arrose être qui je pense a
pris un peu la tête alors dans le grain
faut savoir ce qu'ils iront voir c'est
un peu masqué il ya de la pluie qui
vient ce qu'il ya du vent de danse aura
tout à l'heure on peut être que félix
mérine alors la même voie le crir une 46
mètres qui arrive au maire voit des fois
une voile un peu moins importante que
l'on peut on peut maîtriser le voyez
même avec 46 m² avec un vent qui n'est
pas faux il tient à côté de yole qui ont
un peu de vent ne peut supprimer ça
c'est en fonction de l'équipage qui lie
à un bon allez on va voir
christophe tout de suite christophe
monsieur très dont vous êtes le zidane
de laguiole et si des commentaires oui
mais comme zidane j'ai démissionné à la
première mondiale et christophe nancy
jean reno zidane est ce que je prenne la
main puis un mandat alors je suis avec
muriel masse avec eau salée et elle a
organisé en bateau celui-là qui permet
aux sourds et muets malentendants de
pouvoir participer à ce tour suivant
finale stosur je m'en suis mais
comprendre parce qu'on a avec nous les
1000 masques ne sais pas trop de viol et
de l'écurie at on passe de laguiole
anciennement you m et en fait ils sont
là pour comprendre
suivez comprendre et l'ajustement nous
sommes ne sommes de la en chier coup
cela et c'est ça que je voulais c'est
qu'ils puissent être vraiment là et non
pas loin et eu des catamarans mais
vraiment un temps suivi un produit
unique qu'ils aient leurs propres
produits martinique et pourquoi pas un
jour voir mme sourd et muet à participer
à une course dans un équipage comme le
dit si bien sûr c'est un challenge c'est
mon prochain projet
on est d'accord qu'il ya aucune
contre-indication même si henry sourds
et malentendants on peut très bien sûr
les yeux de lier le sait le premier bois
il doit annoncer le fonds allait couteau
patron ils seront pas dans des postes
comme ça mais je vois bien en quatrième
cinquième boire et les coupeurs by bien
sûr puisqu'ils ont en plus ses capacités
que nous n'avons pas assez le ressenti à
le sentir
voilà vous l'avez vu malgré le handicap
on peut participer ici à ce sport qui
finalement rassemble tout le monde en
tout cas un jean dans un petit moment de
rentrer des voix ce que nous ayons
encore quelques surprises
et puis vous allez me saluer un muret
alsace merci beaucoup merci beaucoup et
belle initiative non à l'exclusion donc
on approche de l'arrivée gens bien sûr
rosette orange est en tête on va faire
reprend rapide avec kelly babur kelly
oui alors nous sommes arrivés au bourg
des anses d'arlet nous voyons les yoles
d'ailleurs lier rose et orange dont vous
venez de parler qui pointe le bout de
son nez
nous sommes avec paulo notre animateur
vedette radio de martigues première la
radio il y a du monde vous êtes sur le
podium à chaque étape à chaque ville
d'arrivée
comment ça se passe comment vous senti
l'ambiance comment vous prenez le pouls
de ce tour 34e tour des yoles ben
l'ambiance on la sent quand on arrive
les spectateurs sont déjà devant et bien
sa vie donc on va passer un excellent
moment
et c'est en fonction aussi de laguiole
qui ont en tête bon si ces ufr champions
on sait qu'on aura devant que des
supporters du fr changement en ce moment
c'est rose est très bien voir dans un
petit moment et bien tous les
supporteurs de rosette
elles seront là et puis en attendant on
fait un peu d'animation pour
et justement faire les personnes
patientent et vous qui êtes là
régulièrement chaque jour est-ce que
vous avez remarqué justement une baisse
de fréquentation on parle beaucoup d'une
baisse de fréquentation par rapport à
l'année dernière par rapport aux années
précédentes
est-ce que ça s'avère bain sous le
podium je n'ai pas trop constaté mais à
part oppresseurs bon c'est un il y avait
une faible participation
mais on était aux entrées avant-hier il
y avait beaucoup de personnes hier aux
personnes ont été données pour le
profane est un peu décalé non je pense
que non
il ya eu peut-être au début c'est normal
on est à la fin du fin juillet puis
souvent que le romand s'était en outre
que ça démarre est vraiment mais là on
sent qu'il ya encore beaucoup plus de
vacanciers qui arrive
merci beaucoup paulo alors on va vous
faire découvrir un petit ce tout ce
public qui regarde d'ailleurs la télé en
même temps qu'ils vont se voir en direct
à la télévision
on va les renvoyer on va voir ces bébés
voilà
quand tu vois là oui oui il ya
certainement le grand écran mais on
salue tout le monde et vous allez à là
exactement maintenant il se voit juste
avant de rejoindre la plage pour
l'arrivée des premiers hommes merci
beaucoup
kelly beauvois trouve bien sûr de
l'arrivée des vacations avec que cette
grande voix officielle de rosette orange
donc qui fait la course devant show week
a fait son banquier a passé sa bouée à
laquelle elle a quand même deux heures
10 de retard par rapport à la première
yeux l'ufr champlan et l'ailleurs qui se
fait 2e laguiole un peu plus de deux
heures lier le ctd m aider il faut un
beau ventre et envoyer le vin est passé
vraiment on ne peut pas arriver à la
plage comme ça on voit au loin et alan
chaudière via les bateaux qui sont
mouillés donc elle est allée là il a
fait son board qui vont pour aller le
long de tout près de la côte et puis
elle a reviré vous soumettre au milieu
de la baie où se recentre et donc sous
un bon d'abord à mieux comprendre les
petites rafales pour entrer aux anses
d'arlet pour aller virer la ligne de
coupé la ligne d'arrivée cieux c'est
debout et qui sont tout près de la plage
mais elle est bien là devant alors vu le
fasse la part dont a vu ça que ce café
aux et orange
eh bien il aura manche est carrément ils
arrivent et ils se retrouvent bâbord
amure à aller vers la côte et je pense
que l'uefa champions va faire la même
chose pour essayer de se re toujours se
rapprocher mais aller vers comme le vin
et honore donc on ne peut pas aller tout
droit vers la plage on pique vers la
violence chaudière pour arriver au
maximum et on revient sur un bord
tribord amure pour couper la ligne
d'arrivée
oui je vous ai dit l'arrivée des
arrivées aux données ne sont jamais très
sympa ce que le vent change des fois en
un grand nord dès lors non on a inventé
s nord-est voyez les choses sont en
train d'aller tout doucement et on va
voir lorsque cette huile qui était le
deuxième c'était des medef lors du
passage elle va se retrouver tribord
amure et nous verrons si le bord qu'elle
a fait en ayant attaqué avant parce
qu'elle amasse l attaque havre un navire
et avant pratiquement avant vous êtes
nous allons voir si le bord et est
favori mais je pense que vous êtes va
tenir quand même laissant alors on le
saura tout à l'heure lorsque sûr
l'eau qui à des titres ici qui font que
la laguiole produits titrisés elle
montre vraiment où on a quand même le
grand patron à coke est à la barre il en
veut il veut arriver devant bon y'a pas
de raison de faire autrement alors
justement aux est donc qui a pris noté
de ce qui lui est arrivé dans la
dernière fois donc rosetti voulez peut
se rapprocher de la côte va devoir tirer
un bon parce que là là c'est pas
possible
là c'était pas possible il ya déjà trois
blessés comme sete.fr au niveau de la
rue rappelle que c'était bien vu passer
à une 08
mais là le façon de refuser un job on va
voir là on va plus l'image de recettes
au rouge alors on nageait fa caraïbes
qui va arriver à quatre minutes et 14
secondes quatre minutes 4 minutes 14
secondes donc pour jf à un caraïbes en
3e 4e position on rappelle que la yole
de tête si donc rosette/orange suivi de
cette idée mdf mais attention parce que
là effectivement on sent que leïla ben
ali à des bateaux donc ils vont pas ils
vont pas pouvoir aller plus loin oisel
valence et je pense que vous êtes va
virer avant parce que vous étiez déjà au
maximum
non c'était bien ma vie mais avant ils
essaient de se retrouver ce qui pourra
mieux mais où êtes vous êtes va prendre
le tribord oz va prendre le tribord va
se retrouver sous le vent si vous allez
va laisser monter non elle va se
retrouver au vent elle va continuer
continuer continuer et virer tous se
mettre devant la yole c'était donc ces
deux vont repartir vers la ligne
d'arrivée la ligne d'arrivée tout cas
son tribord amure mais voyez le levant
le vent ne donne pas la vie vous êtes va
virer mais n'a pas elle va prendre 20
différents à garder le vent qu'au procès
tdm c'est en train d'abattre d'un bac
parce qu'il peut pas faire autrement
parce que c'est le monde
filmé en train d'abattre et ne font pas
la ligne bleue moment de leur tournée
vers l'intérieur toutes les deux mais
avec le vent en essayant de voir si ce
vent qui est passé au no 6 avons pour
face aux nordistes se maintient pour les
faire monter comme on dit un petit peu
se rapprocher de la ligne d'arrivée pour
le moment laissant ni loi il à l'abri
d'acquérir pas de faire un koala un
petit café on va voir pour moi
ça pétille à ben jawad envoyé quand elle
est libre quand pleyel pas cela jibril
numéro deux mais toulon rentre vers le
front vers le fond de la baie côté 1
chaudière côté bout parce que de l'autre
côté contrairement aux habitudes de
l'autre côté sur les côtés extérieurs
c'est pas le moment comme habib baldé
c'est là bas qu'il faut aller de manière
avisée même si on fait après deux bons
coups coopeval voilà donc on rappelle
les positions roses et oranges et tdm
edf
mais attention c'est pas fini c'est le
stand commun name également chaque lundi
du côté d installer à l'or il ya
également donc payer faire sans florent
troisième gfa quatrième saut varie petit
avion c'est comme christophe phare de ré
rapidement christophe parce que la
proche de l'arrivée peut-être comme un
petit bords à tirer pour les viols
christoph hein voilà voilà que juste à
côté de nous nous avons des caraïbes
on est également ufr chant flanc 1ce
marek petit navire et puis un peu plus
loin on voit un peu plus loin on a
souvent on est également un outil temps
en
bien plus loin je vois également je
crois que c'est d'ailleurs de ce même
également qu'un peu plus loin en tout
cas juste devant nous on a trois yole
qui sont en train de filer ensemble
quasiment sur le même même
perpendiculaire là il ya donc chef à
illies auf1 eux le ferment du père jean
floch marie boutinot merci beaucoup
christophe donc rosette orange qui va
donc franchir cette ligne d'arrivée mais
attention attention parce que
rosette a viré rosette qui va enfin
gagner une victoire d'étape sur ce 34ème
tour de martinique des yoles rondes ça y
est c'est fait pour équipage donc que
dargaud voilà qui retrouve un peu des
couleurs qui devait nous regarderons
contre l'état peut pour les supporteurs
franciscaine regarder effectivement vrai
peu au niveau du mât ont célébré cette
victoire parce qu il la fallait il la
fallait pour un rose et orange
impossible donc de finir un tour sans
gagner une étape c'est aider mdf encore
une triste nouvelle mais ça s'est joué
pau fait deux secondes les gens pètent
de second seulement
bon c'était des fdf qui a tenté quatre
tenues
7e première place et qu'il espérait mais
qui a vu passer et c'est là qu'on veut
parler vraiment de la pépite qui a vu
passer donc un gros mapipi et rosette
orange donc deuxième place pour inciter
des m
edf donc du côté dix ans
d'arles et puis on attend l'arrivée donc
de faire chanter lors le leader du
classement général qui s'est tellement
repris au moins trois minutes ou à
donner
abonné à donner a donné trois minutes au
moins la brasserie lorraine sahara et
les âges une nouvelle qui n'a pas très
bien fonctionné aujourd'hui ça il faut
le dire pour l'équipage la rhinois qui
voulaient peut faire la course avec une
affaire champions mais y'a quelque chose
ça n'a pas forcément fonctionner donc
pour gianni rémy qui va perdre du temps
donc au classement général mais qui va
quand même resté deuxième donc de ce
classement général alors bagarre pour la
3e place entre un rosette par vous êtes
là ufr chanflor jet pack a raillé donc
sénat ba gala pour la troisième place on
rappelle que tout à l'heure au niveau de
la bouée il y avait 3 57 points fr et
4,14 import jf ados qui avaient tard est
à peu près une dizaine de secondes entre
les aider en alu fr est allé tout au
bout pour virer dgf a même eu va tenter
de rentrer normes des quais piraterie
conseil va devoir il va vers l'accord
qui contrôle le vent soit fait le film
est bon donc il va voir losc s'est fait
virer va virer n'ont peut-être pas
évident parce qu'il est quand même
derrière là il est en train d'essayer de
prendre la tête et peut-être se
retrouver devant pourquoi pas oui mais
là je vous dis félix mérine y forcent
pas avec sa 46 m² il a sur ce qu'il lui
faut ici coller les deux joueurs qui
sont arrivés devant à savoir vous êtes
orange et c'était des médias passant des
yankees ont deux heures et quelques
deux heures vingt de retard sauf un
petit peu moins bon et puis le bracelet
lorraine de l'avoir mis un peu derrière
ça ne s'arrange un petit peu donc
aujourd'hui on aménage et les forces
pour la tenaille on est en train de
virer
elle fait le petit bourbon fait
d'habitude parce que le vin est revenue
peut-être mort death
venu à peu près normale on va voir le
coin je pense que j'ai ma vie rires
lorsque gf1 va arriver avant l ufr
chansons à mon avis voilà dans la vie va
arriver avant le 10 mai il ne semblait
pas trop ils contrôlent sakho souffre
gars vraiment il faut qu'ils mettent des
dix minutes entre lui et bat ce cri
lorraine ceux qui seront sans souci
principal ne pas avoir d' à paris n'est
pas mon problème
et continuez comme ça vous voyez à quoi
dans la vie tester la vitesse des
d'hillion sûr pour le moment là yosef
avant un petit peu moins vite soyez
discret l'hépatite c petite vitesse en
2003-2004 à baisieux de petit temps
comme on dit non même des jets je crois
qu'on a huge bag la validation sa
troisième série babeau avec cette idée
mdf qui a raté de peu la victoire
d'étape
oui alors alors enfin on a envie de dire
enfin pour reprendre du poil de la bête
et vous arrivé en deuxième position
aujourd'hui
oui une petite note de déception quand
même parce que là la première place
était quand même un bond de diamètre le
vent se lève débit le bateau suiveur
nous ont beaucoup gênés à ne l'a pas des
fous de qui fait quand vous étiez
direction nous dépasse le négoce
satisfait de cette deuxième place du
bourg
déjà nous consoler de ne pas dire pour
le moment au sahara tunisien
et puis pour le supporter avec me
supporte tous les jours même dans la
déveine à l'évaluation conjointe sino
ben johnson innovant le directeur d'edf
le gntc tdm c'est d'abord firme
on a eu la médaille d'or de la ville du
lamentin aussi de seniors gars c'est pas
grave que l'on a réussi à faire mieux
la nouvelle on va commencer à prendre
les réglages et j'espère que là
sera mûr et bien on se dirige tout de
suite bien rétablissement rose et orange
merci beaucoup kelly babeau avec gfa
caraïbes qui va donc arrivé en 3e
position donc pour christophe d'aidé qui
rêvait d'un podium qu'il espérait yom
qui a été déclassé elle suit une
réclamation portant son encontre par
l'équipage
est innovant dont on le voit ainsi cette
troisième classe ton espérait donc sur
le podium
pour gfk rahim du côté des licences dans
les puits on a le leader du taux qui va
arriver attention il faut corriger ça ne
peut arriver mais yo ké fè yo ké fait
parce que look avec un 9 h au floc
arrivé qu'on voulait le cadeau mais ce
dont ça mais bon ça va être bon ça va
être bon 4,57 quatre minutes 57 pour
rejet fakharani 4 minutes et 57 secondes
ah ouais je suppose que tous les
supporter donc franciscaine sont aux
anges et surtout fait de rosette orange
parce que ben oui bravo il fallait se
remobiliser fallait soit relancé même si
effectivement bon on sait que c'est pas
forcément jouable il ya la victoire de
ce tome est là il va falloir jouer les
victoires d'étape pour aco et son
équipage il reste encore deux étapes
alors les fermes qui est fait à
champfleur alors effet un champ clos qui
arrive à sec 25 sec 20 sec à l'est le
point avec kelly babeau avec un coup
avec ya beaucoup de courant
à gauche pour reprenait à 7 cette course
en faire on envie de dire enfin vous
avez eu beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
déboires depuis le début de ce tour oui
c'est vrai on a joué de malchance
aujourd'hui on voulait à tout prix
gagner pour nos supporters sont restés
ailleurs à nous attendre
hélas cette victoire à ses poules
comment ça s'est passé cette course
qu'est ce qui a fait la différence
aujourd'hui par rapport aux autres je
vous dis je pense qu'on a un tout petit
peu plus de voix on avait les bons
option on est allé vers le rocher du
diamant et après on est venu en 2011 ce
qui a fait la différence à mercier alors
pour demain qu'est ce que qu'est ce que
vous prévoyez justement pour cette
prochaine étape
bon c'est vrai pour nous on a perdu le
tour alors on va essayer de jouer la
victoire
la victoire devrait se jouer la victoire
avec trois étapes ok très bien merci
on se dirige les ufr sont d'accord on
son voilà donc à qu un coup bien sûr
réaliste à bon compte quand même
réaliste on a perdu le tour dit-il voici
boissy se marrer ça se disent au bar etc
si son arrêt que petit navire qui va
arriver en cinquième position et
brasserie lorraine qui perd beaucoup de
temps alors là bras si c'est vraiment la
mauvaise mauvaise mauvaise opération du
genre brasserie qui sera toujours 2e à
leur appel du général mais qui va
carrément offrir cette victoire du taux
à fr
chancelant donc sur marek ainsi 57 pour
se marrer que petit navire 6,57 pour se
marrer que peut-il averlant je disais
que brasserie lorraine sarah vit bien
sûr avec cette mauvaise opération même
si même si allez on va dire qu'il reste
encore deux étapes on va embarquer
quelqu'un voilà et attention il va
falloir virer il ya déjà un petit peu
plus de deux minutes
indikar entre ufr chanflor hebras blu
ray de rappeler que l'uefa champions est
déjà donc arriver à 5 min 30 sec de
rosette orange et puis c'était le duel
tant espéré tant attendu on espérait
vraiment quelque chose ce matin jean je
m'attendais beaucoup mieux de cet
équipage marinois je suis un peu déçu
quand même parce que nos par yves fs ayo
télé a beau matin en faire la course
avec le faire rester à côté
mettez caillou d'ouvrir ou rester day
non non ça n'a pas fonctionné
aujourd'hui
oui je pense que l'énergie qui a été
déployé hier soir il veut aux marins que
mon petit doigt me dit qu'il est arrivé
chez eux
ben on n'a pas pu refaire ça en douce
alors qu'elle y pas beau avec christophe
des dgf à karim qui tient en fait son
podium oui nous sommes avec tristes
heures d'aidé on laisse de trucks ont
fait rapidement la radio minime et on a
le constater dès maintenant ils savent
d'aidé troisième position où il avait
fait aujourd'hui vous l'aviez dit oui
oui on est sur la même dynamique là le
groupe a fait un super boulot attention
voilà on continue à basse classe voilà
on travaille toujours on croit toujours
un nom et ben jusqu'au dernier jour
voilà jusqu'au dernier jour mais on va
continuer on va se battre aux motos
classement qui a fait la différence
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui a fait que
vous ayez pu atteindre 7 un troisième
temps
mais on ne s'est pas affolé c'est un
long bord de vent arrière et on marchait
bien on était bien réglée donc sans
affolement ni revenu sur la tête de
course et on a bien bossé l'entraidé
entre les deux mains qu'est ce que vous
prévoyez continuer continuer à
travailler pour tenter de remonter